there's a YouTuber who went viral who
has created a machine to slap a chicken
fast enough to see if it could cook
okay he said why is this even a question
we're wondering well there are 20 years
of reddits talking about the mathematics
behind us and why it actually would be
possible but nobody's built the machine
to figure it out so I'm gonna do that so
he built this thing and there's like a
time lapse and he actually does it and
it was such an intriguing video that I
was like are there any questions in the
Pokemon space that I could build
something for to find out the answer to
and there was so the unlock here is if
you're diversifying your consumption
kind of Storytelling Frameworks then you
could pull those Frameworks and think
about how could I apply that to my new